*ethaniplier sits*
*ethaniplier noises*
PERFECT needs more
Okay, got the beard done
still not right.... AHA
*Cough cough*
Hello every-- *Cough*
*deep, attempt of markimoo's voice* Hello, everybody!
and welcome back to more of Surgeon Simulator! Now, the last time that I played this, I did not complete my goal in
operation so we have to go back today and show
Those assholes what. We. Can. Do.
And we will not stop and we will not give up
Until, we reach OUR GOALS. So let's just get right back into it and play some games shall, we?
All right let's get into this. And let's go, hello sir would you like a heart transplant
By the most handsome man in the entire world
Huehuehueheu Hehehehe AHAHAHHE AHA
All right let's see
Let's see. Let's see here. All right let's see. All right let's see. All right let's see
What do we do here all right let's see, oh?
Mr. Saw, oh you're gonna--
Oh, you asshole! Oh you asshole! Oh you-- oh you're a real asshole
OH YOU'RE-- OH YOU ASSHOLE! ARE YOU FUCKING MAD? OH YOU FUCKING ASSHOLE
All right, I'm just gonna take this heart, put it there. Pat, pat, mister. You're on your way-
To a better place. A better place indeed. Nurse!
NURSE! NURSE! NURSE!
Where's my scalpel? Nurse! He's falling off the face of the earth! Nurse, he needs your assistance!
Why's there no one here with me? Why am I in a drug-induced--
*Weird chebacca-like noise*
Nurse, how do I get his ribs open? Nurse, I can't use any of these materials
NuUURSseeE
He's being a little fubbly, bubbly biatch! He's being a little fubbly, bubbly bitch with his saw!
Mister fubbly, wubbly! He's being a little fubber Jim with his fubberknuckle bitch, bitch
NURSE!
Even with, my strong arms I cannot get the saw to work on the man's chest. Nurse he makes my heart--
He makes my heart sad, nurse, in times like, this i like to
Be appreciative about what I have. Because this man here-
He's going to die
But not me. Not today
No! I will not die and I will not fail so, we have to save this man's life!
No, more drugs for me. This is a drug-free zone. I am the perfect man. I've got no faults I've got-
Oh, fuck. Not again
All right, we got our hammer back. Now we just need to do a little thwacking. Just wacking around here.
Oh, don't be such a little man! Don't be such a little bitch with your ribs going everyWHERE
AMY! AMY!
I can't get the-- I can't get his ribs open amy!
AMY! AMY! AMYYY! AMMEEYY!! Amy! Amy! Amy! Amy! Amyyy! *Cry noises* *Sobbing* Amyyy!
Sir, would you like to learn about space? I love space! If nasa-
Came to me today and said, we wanna shove a man into space, we wanna shove a man right into space's anus, I'd be the first in line
No questions asked. I'd leave EVERYTHING behind! Even Chica. And that's saying a lot. But, it's proving how
much I truly
love. Space.
Look at this shirt. What does this shirt say?-- look at this shirt-- look at the shir-- look at it! What does it say? NASA! And if my arms-- if my arms
Want to go into space I am! I am the handsomest
Man in the world and if I want to go into space, I WILL! It'll be my dream it'll be my
Destiny and I will achieve my, goals just as, we will achieve this surgery because I am not
Going to let this man down! I am going to use this man as a symbol of respect and a symbol of
space and I will be both in space and respected
Yeah I know what I need. I know what I need. I've got my playbutton with me
We should be able to do this now. Sir?
Sir, you know who I am?
Do you know who I am sir?
*Weird noise*
I'll fix your bones! That is a promise! That is a promise, sir, I will be committed. I will be
Committed to saving your life, and that is a Markiplier promise. Every
Single day, I will be here
Protecting you. Every single day. And if I don't,
I'll eat 90 ghost peppers! I'll butt chug an entire glass of pepper juice, sir!
Sir!
Sir, are you with me? Are you with me?  I'm Markiplier
Don't go away, Don't go away!
Keep your eyes open!
Stay with me!
NOOOOO!
*Sobbing*
*More sobbing*
I tried
And I failed
And I should be better. For you
Because
You're here. Day, after day and I know that you all have so much respect
And that's the foundation of the chair. Respect. And I know
That I just-- haven't done enough. But I
Promise
I promise that I'll do more
I'll eat 40, 50, 60, ghost peppers a day
To make sure that I keep my promise
Because I am a man of my word. I'll do it
We didn't save the man but, we did have a good time
I'm still handsome as ever. I'm gonna leave this here for today. But we will be back
insistently
Tomorrow. So thank you everybody so much for watching and as always I will see you in the next video buh-bye
*Outro music*